regardez qu'on va parler aujourd'hui
alors si vous intéresser aux ordinateurs
si vous intéresser aux ordinateurs
puissants et aux machines qui marche
très bien qu'ils performent qui sont
coulés tout eh bien on va parler de
cette petite machine là cette petite
machine là c'est un produit de aster
s'appelle le concept des trois concepts
décès une gamme qui est destiné aux
professionnels aux créatifs aux
freenautes
je vous explique et ça ça c'est un des
modèles d'entrée de gamme de la gamme
c'est une gamme pour professionnels donc
on n'est pas sur les ordinateurs qui
sont dépourvus de spécifications
techniques
c'est une machine qui est quand même
extrêmement performante je vous le
détailler dans quelques instants
mais juste avant seule focus confinement
corner les blues parce que si vous vous
souvenez vous ai demandé il ya quelques
jours de m'envoyer vos vidéos pour
expliquer comment vous viviez me parlez
de vous de votre vie durant le
confinement à cause du coronavirus et
justement je publie chaque jour clean de
vos vidéos qui expliquent comment ça se
passe donc aujourd'hui ne déroge pas à
la règle et n'oubliez pas devant voyez
vous vos vidéos vous avez l'e-mail qui
s'affiche ici ses amours
@ monsieur gros point fr parce que oui
on parle d'amour bonjour monsieur creux
bonjour à tous elle présente jean karl
bio s'invite dans l'aisne à saint
quentin
je travaille en grande distribution est
bon je vous cache pas que c'est plutôt
compliqué en ce moment par ces temps
difficiles très difficile je dirais même
je pense à vous je pense aux familles si
vous pouvez éviter de sortir ne sortait
pas penser à votre bien-être avant tout
voir c'est la santé cédant à est rare
donc faut la préserver
et je pense aussi à mes collègues de
travail olivier et tous les autres qui
travaillons d'arrache-pied en ce moment
pour vous puissiez quand vous pouvez
sortir acheter des copains vous faire
vos courses et croyez moi c'est pas
facile donc je n'ose penser à eux
voilà bon bon courage en tout cas faut
se tenir les coudes
allez à bientôt ça va merci à toi de
m'avoir envoyé cette vidéo et n'oublie
pas vous m'envoyez de votre vidéo ali
mail amour @ muscle groupe point fr plus
on se revoit d'amour avec demain plus on
communique plus on reste connectés
malgré la distance et magrets
confinement et mieux ça se passera sur
ce on va aujourd'hui parler d'un
ordinateur va pas et c'est petit mais
qu'elle n'a pourquoi est-ce que acer a
lancé la gamme concept ds que vous le
savez si vous ne le savez pas mettez la
pause et marqué le mois en bas en
commentaire des proies
selon vous pourquoi est-ce que acer
alors c'est cette fameuse gamme concède
là c'est parti c'est bon l'ami lecture
vous avez deviné
ok alors je vous explique en fait
concept d n'existait pas avant
elle s'adresse à une niche de population
plutôt à des professionnels en fait il
ya eu un constat c'est que 15% des
personnes qui utilisent les ordinateurs
predator 2 à serques et la gamme game
mix ordinateurs basés vraiment axé sur
la performance race et design et comment
on peut retrouver dans les années dans
les ordinateurs deux gaming et bien en
fait acer s'est rendu compte que 15 %
des personnes qui poussent et laissant
ses ordinateurs là ne l'utilisé pas pour
aller jouer pour le gaming mais bel et
bien pour la performance et notamment à
usage professionnel du coup ils sont dit
ok on se rend compte que donc il ya un
réel besoin
il ya des personnes qui ont besoin de
vraiment de performance à tel point
qu'il leur faut des machines est
extrêmement puissante extrêmement
performante mais que par contre il s'en
fiche complètement du design de gaming
s'en fichent du gaming
il ne faut pas rester un petit micro il
ne joue pas donc globalement ça ne les
intéresse pas d'où l'idée de créer une
nouvelle gamme et c'est comme ça que la
gamme concept des aînés donc la gamme
concept d regroupe quatre modèles le
concept des 3 le concept des 5
le concept 17 et le concept des neuf
vous en douterez du moins performant si
on peut dire ça comme ça qu'on plus
performants la machine de compétition
ici j'ai un concept détroit on va faire
un tour complet de ce produit on va
regarder s'il intéressant s'il est fait
pour vous et après je vous expliquer
quel concept d est fait pour vous et
s'il faut se positionner au mieux donc
on va commencer par le commencement
c'est à dire on prend des acteurs dans
ses mains c'est le poids pour moi
concède dessins produits quand même
relativement lourd que je trouve nourrit
fait pourtant devient
35 kg et lorsque je vais le comparer à
un macbook pro 13 pouces et bien j'ai
l'impression qu'un dock est quand même
beaucoup plus lourd et notamment c'est
le concept des trois pros c'est vrai
qu'il ya une différence de 300 grammes
mais je puis vous êtes serait lorsque
vous les comparez à la main vous le
sentez on est un lecteur d'empreintes
digitales pour le déverrouiller
extrêmement facilement et façon
complètement sécurisé on a une surface
qui est totalement en céramique qui lui
confère vraiment une qualité extrêmement
premium patrick est vachement
intéressant c'est la flexibilité vous
avez au niveau l'écran vous pouvez le
bout g20 à 180° en termes de design
c'est une machine qui n'a rien
d'exceptionnel qui a débord assez grand
en haut et en bas autour l'écran mais
qui est là pour faire le taf essaie
vraiment qu'on vient chercher là dessus
au niveau l'écran d'un dali ps et du rcd
du 15,6 pouces de l'écran full hd 1920
par 1080 ratio 16 9ème mais la grande
force de ce produit là c'est la qualité
d'affichage
vous avez un écran qui est certifié
pantone vous avez un delta e qui est
inférieur à 2 et vous avez une gamme de
couleurs d'essayer p3 à 100%
voilà donc des couleurs qui sont
complètement fidèle pour les créatifs
pour que ce que vous voyez à l'écran
c'est ce que vous allez retrouver en
réalité côté audio et ya rien de bien
complètement dingue on a deux haut
parleurs qui sont situées en dessous du
châssis à droite et à gauche
le son est globalement assez médium il
n'y a pas une spatialisation de dingue
c'est assez étriqués je suis assez déçu
parce que quand on cherche un produit
plutôt pour les créatifs et notamment
pour le montage vidéo on s'attendrait à
voir une bonne qualité ça passe un peu
un effet whaou ok je peux travailler sur
ma bécane j'ai une très bonne qualité
j'en profite et ça c'est assez moyen
la meilleure expérience à se fera grâce
à une prise jack côté performances il
est quand même plutôt pas mal on
retrouve en intel core i7 2 9e
génération 6 coeurs cadencé à 2,66 gates
le stockage est pas mal vous avez un
terrain avec un disque qui tourne à 5400
tours par minute mais également 512 giga
de stockage en ssd pour faire tourner le
système vous avez donc toute une partie
pour le stockage une partie pour ce
système
ça fait tâche la caméra fixe et une
nvidia quadro t1000 avec 4 gigaoctets de
mémoire dédiée gddr5 bien c'est pas à la
machine la plus performante on est sur
le modèle entrée de gamme du concept des
saf et la faire mais là où il ya un pas
qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a recherché sur cette
machine là c'est le silence on veut une
machine très performante ne veux pas
avoir un ventilateur ne veux pas avoir
un bruit de réacteur à côté nous on vous
dit quelque chose de très silencieux et
là effectivement on a des ventilateurs
aéro blake 3d c'est exactement la bac se
soit retrouvé dans les ordinateurs
predator les ordinateurs de gaming
lasserre et vous allez avoir moins de 40
décibels de bruyne et ça c'est bien
l'autonomie annoncée par acer fait 12
heures moi j'arrive pas exactement à 12
heures j'ai un petit peu en dessous ça
reste très complexe à mesurer parce que
ça dépend de vous de vos usages si vous
voulez quelque chose qui pédalent
énormément si vous demandez des rangs du
très lourd si vous demandez à skis et
beaucoup de performances
l'autonomie d'un fond comme neige au
soleil si à côté de ça vous l'utiliser
comme un ordinateur de bureautique vous
allez vous en rapprocher
mais c'est pas du tout l'adn de cette
machine donc bon l'autonomie ça va
vraiment dépendre de vous et de vos
besoins cotées au s entendent sur un
windows 10pro le clavier est bien
complet je trouve que la course est
quand même relativement longue mais on a
un beau retour touche donc très
confortable à utiliser mes impôts qui
est intéressant c'est le rétroéclairage
couleurs rendre qui est reposant pour
les yeux donc si vous trouvez dans une
pièce où il ya assez peu de lumière ça
va éviter vous fatiguer les yeux
davantage le trackpad la taille est
assez petit standard vous me direz bien
alignées par rapport au clavier par
rapport à la partie centrale du clavier
mais vu l'espace disponible
je m'attendais à quelque chose d'un peu
plus grand et ça je trouve ça un peu
dommage peut être amélioré sur une
version ultérieure
on est petite webcam pour aller faire un
peu de visioconférence en 720p
rien de bien donne mais ça fait le
boulot la connectique est pas trop mal
dans l'absolu ce que je trouve un peu
bizarre c'est l'emplacement de la prise
pour ni recharger votre bécane vous fait
vraiment venir courir le câble le long
ordinateur je trouve pas ça idéal après
c'est probablement réfléchie par rapport
aux besoins de ventilation du produit on
a une prise hdmi pour brancher un
moniteur externe et lorsqu'on est un
créatif ça c'est extrêmement important
on a une prise usb c'est la 3 prises usb
on a une prise rj45 mais ce que je vais
arrêter là tu sais que hong hao d'état
qui s'adresse aux créatifs pourquoi ne
pas intégrer de lecteur de carte sd ça
aurait vraiment un sens puisqu'on parle
aux créatifs si vous êtes un créatif en
photo si vous êtes un créatif en vidéo
vous prenez votre carte sd vous la
branchez et là je peux pas ça c'est
dommage ça aurait été vraiment point
d'appel pour les créatifs photos vidéos
on regarde et on a de quoi se brancher
facilement ça évite de passer par la
dette externe ou par un câble
là j'ai du mal à comprendre à côté de ça
la chine affiche ce qui se fait de mieux
en ce moment on a du wifi 6 du bluetooth
5.0 et surtout ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'on a trois ans de
garantie
ça c'est plutôt bien sert maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous allez pouvoir
réellement faire avec
est ce que c'est ce concept des lacs
qu'il vous faut ou est ce que c'est un
autre concept dès qu'il vous faut ce
qu'on va faire ce qu'on fait un peu
autour de la gamme dans la gamme concept
d
vous avez le concept des 3 le concept
des 5
le concept des 7 et le concept des neuf
on va vraiment venir les partager en
deux la partie 3 5 et la partie 7 9
la partie 3,5 sait plus qui va être de
la 2d et la partie 7 9 salles plus est
de la 3d vous allez avoir ici de la
capca uh
d ici vous êtes en full hd et nous c'est
cette machine qu'on a aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que sur la
partie de dés on va plus s'adresser ici
on retouche photo tout ce qu'ils veulent
photoshop tout ce qui va avec lightroom
c'est ici mais également ici sur de la
vidéo moi je vous conseille vraiment de
prendre tout de suite d'emblée un 32
gigaoctets drame ça vous évitera drame
et vous donnera plus de fluidité
si vous alliez être si vous allez voir
ce qu elle mieux vous allez pouvoir
faire de la 3d vous allez pouvoir
utiliser de l'autocar et surtout avoir
une machine extrêmement performante qui
me permettra d'aller plus loin pour
envisager le futur
il ya d'autres outils qui est
extrêmement intéressant vous y retrouvez
ici sur cette idée et bien c'est la
palette concept d la palette concept
belle vous donne plein d'informations
sur votre cpu sur votre gpu et sur votre
mémoire
en gros sur votre processeur votre carte
graphique et utilisation de votre
mémoire vous avez un truc est
extrêmement intéressant pour moi ça
situe juste ici c'est le créateur des
séries p3c le profil de couleur vous
avez trois profils de couleurs soient
créateurs de cp3 configurer là dessus
soit dci p 3 c'est un peu plus verts
soient natifs
on est plus sur quelque chose d'un peu
violée ça dépend de vos besoins
personnellement je laisse sur créateur
des cp 3 c ce qui me correspond mieux
je fais a signé et on en parle plus on
se faisait à trouver des paramètres ici
pour la surveillance surveillance de
votre cpu de votre gpu le système un peu
de la même manière avec l'utilisation de
votre mémoire
toutes les informations concernant votre
réseau ethernet montant et descendant le
wifi votre disque les vitesses de
lecture et vitesse d'écriture votre
disque 0 mais également votre disque dur
donc la question à se poser aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il vous et quels sont vos
besoins
est ce que vous êtes un monteur une
monteuse est ce que vous faites de la 3d
qu'est ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce que vous allez faire plus
tard puisque ça ordinateur que vous
allez garder dans le temps minimum 3 ans
c'est le temps de la garantie qu'elle
est votre métier
et quelle va être l'évolution de votre
métier dans les années à venir c'est
toujours un petit peu compliqué mais
c'est vraiment une question à se poser
puisque vous êtes sur un investissement
machine 7 mai canal
concept des droits que j'utilise mois
coûte la modique somme de 1699 euros
plus vous allez racheter des options et
plus ça coûtera cher et si vous monter
tout en haut tout en tout auront
jusqu'au concept des neuf vous en
douterez ça va vous coûter beaucoup plus
cher si d'ailleurs fondateur qui
intéresse vous a mis un lien en bas dans
la description et c'est vraiment mon
avis tout l'intérêt de ce produit là moi
je trouve intéressant moi je trouve pas
mal je trouve que acer a fait plutôt un
beau boulot avec une machine qui est
bien l'écran est vraiment top
il a des faiblesses c'est dommage
j'aurais trouvé ça intéressant que acer
est beaucoup plus loin pour avoir une
machine encore mieux un plus grand
trackpad vraiment réfléchi pour les
créatifs
je trouve qu'il est beaucoup trop petit
ce trackpad si vous regardez par rapport
à d'autres machines plus d'aidés
créative vous trouvez choses un peu plus
grands tout plus de confort ça pourrait
être vraiment intéressant pour une
deuxième version de cette machine là le
fait d'améliorer aussi la partie audio
ça serait extrêmement importante
puisqu'on va parler aussi aux personnes
qui font de la vidéo avec un écran 4 k
c'est dommage d'avoir une expérience
audio un peu à l'emporte-pièce la
machine que j'ai testé aujourd'hui le
concept des trois n'est pas parfaite
elle est plutôt bien elle est
intéressante si vous travaillez sur la
photo c'est une machine qui peuvent
vraiment fait pour vous et si vous avez
des visages un peu plus gourmand si vous
faites vraiment du multi calque je vous
invite à monter sur les machines un peu
plus puissante sur le concept des 5 ou
pourquoi pas le concept 17 le neuf c'est
vraiment être ni chez je pense pour des
personnes qui ont des gros gros bourg
aux besoins de performance dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez comment vous
le trouvez cette machine est ce que vous
allez trouver intéressant parce que vous
pensez que là ça va plutôt dans le bon
sens par rapport à cette bécane là
est-ce que vous utilisez un predator à
usage professionnel et est ce que vous
pourriez switcher sur un produit de la
gamme concept des marques et moi ça on
va en commentaire et n'oubliez pas
d'envoyer votre vidéo de soutien par
rapport au courant d'un virus comment ça
se passe chez vous pendant le
confinement est ce que tout se passe
bien est ce que ça va parce que vous
avez des messages d'encouragement si
vous avez des activités professionnelles
que vous pouvez exercer à distance et
que vous manquez le client n'hésitez pas
à me l'envoyer on partage tout ça sur ce
je vous embrasse donne rendez vous dès
demain pour étudier par l'etec allée des
bisous et de l'amour à demain ciao
[Musique]
oh
où
vous
[Musique]
où
aux escanaux